another beautiful day to bust some myths
hmm interesting
what am i having for lunch
wait
a minute
i'm sorry but the old michelle can't come
to the phone right now
why?
oh cause she's dead
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and propaganda
source
today i'm going to be talking about a recent
study it's on the sunscreen ingredient octocrylene
turning into benzophenone according to the
paper benzophenone causes mutations cancer
and endocrine disruptions i wasn't going to
do a whole thing on this paper because it
only really got a lot of attention in france
and nowhere else but then i saw that i was
cited in it twice
like and subscribe if you're into sunscreen
propaganda and click the nerdification bell
if you want hot piping skincare propaganda
so this paper benzophenone accumulates over
time from the degradation of octocrylene in
commercial sunscreen products it's a bit weird
it's open access and i've linked it in the
description if you want to give it a read
let's start by looking at what the researchers
actually did in a science paper this is in
the methods and results sections and this
part is pretty standard
octocrylene is a pretty common sunscreen ingredient
and under certain conditions it can turn into
another chemical called benzophenone which
the paper paints out to be really really nasty
more on that later the researchers bought
17 different sunscreens 3 bottles of each
and 16 of these had octocrylene
they measured the amount of benzophenone in
them right after buying them and then they
kept them for six weeks at 40 degrees celsius
in stability testing this approximates one
year of normal storage then they tested the
benzophenone levels again they found that
at the start there was benzophenone in all
of the octocrylene sunscreens an average of
39 parts per million there was barely any
in the one without octocrylene
after the six-week storage they found that
the benzophenone went up in all of the octocrylene
sunscreens by between 15 and almost 200 percent
the average was 75 parts per million of benzophenone
and the sunscreen with the highest concentration
had 435 parts per million
there are some limitations with this study
the most obvious one is that six weeks at
40 degrees celsius isn't quite the same as
one year of normal storage there'll be some
reactions that go at 40 degrees celsius that
wouldn't normally go at room temperature but
based on this study it's probably safe to
say that some octocrylene in sunscreens will
turn into benzophenone over time
is this actually a problem? well this is the
controversial part of this paper the interpretation
of what this means how the paper tries to
put the results into context this is in the
introduction and discussion parts of the paper
if you just read the paper then it seems like
the science is pretty clear benzophenone is
really dangerous snake emoji snake emoji snake
emoji the start of the abstract benzophenone
is a mutagen carcinogen and endocrine disruptor
in the intro there's four chunky paragraphs
on how bad benzophenone is benzophenone is
associated with a wide range of toxicities
including genotoxicity carcinogenicity and
endocrine disruption benzophenone is an established
carcinogen
the problem is the evidence that the authors
cite to show that benzophenone is so incredibly
scary it's mostly in vitro assays studies
in cells in mice and guinea pigs and rats
and zebrafish things we're not this isn't
the scientific consensus in humans at all
the authors cite a few reviews on the risks
of benzophenone in humans in this paper these
reviews looked at the same evidence the in
vitro and animal studies that the authors
looked at and they came to very different
conclusions the international agency on research
in cancer their report concludes that there's
no data in humans there's no solid explanation
for how benzophenone could cause cancer in
humans but because it happened in animals
they can't say whether or not it would also
happen in humans so they basically went *dunno
noise* and put benzophenone in group 2b: possibly
carcinogenic to humans
this sounds pretty bad but it means that it
missed out on group 1 carcinogenic to humans
and group 2a probably carcinogenic to humans
other things in group 2b include lead progestogen-only
contraceptives mobile phone radiation and
aloe vera extract it's a mixed bag so not
exactly as strong as stance as you'd think
from reading the statements in this paper
they also cite the european food safety authority
who did a safety assessment in 2017 as you
probably guessed they were looking at eating
benzophenone which is considered worse than
just putting it on your skin their conclusions:
there is no concern with respect to genotoxicity
the panel concludes that there is no safety
concern for benzophenone under the current
condition of use as a flavoring substance
which again doesn't really match what the
authors of this study are saying but it does
explain the fact that benzophenone isn't on
that eu list of banned ingredients and cosmetics
that clean beauty people like to point to
and it also explains the fact that safety
assessors already know that there's benzophenone
in sunscreens and they're okay with it benzophenone
is a known contaminant in the octocrylene
that gets put into sunscreens it's actually
listed on the safety data sheets from the
suppliers that means that toxicologists do
actually consider the benzophenone that you
rub onto your skin when they're doing safety
assessments for octocrylene sunscreens
octocrylene is used at 10% max in sunscreens
the highest amount measured in the study is
a fair bit higher than 10 percent of the known
benzophenone contamination from popular octocrylene
suppliers but the french federation of beauty
enterprises points out that even with the
highest benzophenone sunscreen from this study
if you apply 18 grams of sunscreen a day you
still end up with less than half a milligram
of benzophenone this is three times less than
the maximum allowed dose if you're eating
it
so how do the authors explain why their conclusions
are so different from the scientific consensus
well they kind of just say that the other
people are wrong "the risks have been underestimated
in both toxicology journal papers and organizational
reports this is unfortunate" not only that
but the authors say that these other people
"can be argued to be unjustified and irresponsibly
reckless"
so all of these scientists who specialize
in human toxicology you can check out their
cvs and conflicts of interest on the efsa
website the eu doesn't mess around when it
comes to regulation they're all wrong but
the authors are right let's look at the authors
there are five authors four of them are from
an ocean research institution one of them
is a human toxicologist but he's retired and
he's not affiliated with any research institutions
but their actual qualifications don't always
matter maybe they have good evidence maybe
they reference other authoritative sources
that are as qualified and reputable as the
iarc and the efsa and maybe they say that
the body of evidence shows that benzophenone
is really dangerous to humans no none of the
references say this the evidence that the
authors cite apart from all the in vitro and
animal studies that experts with much more
expertise have interpreted completely differently
ah a court case lawyers aren't exactly qualified
in toxicology so that doesn't mean much and
supposedly proposition 65
they say under the state of california proposition
65 there is no safe harbor or allowable level
of benzophenone contamination in a product
and they say that this reflects the dangers
of benzophenone so this makes it sound like
california thinks that benzophenone is so
bad that no level should be allowed that's
not how it works prop 65 is a law that makes
companies put up warning signs about potential
toxic chemicals you might know it from the
coffee and potato chips and disneyland give
you cancer signs that went viral a while back
firstly this regulation obviously results
in a lot of warning signs that don't really
mean much in reality this is because it takes
a hazard based approach which is what i talked
about in my clean beauty video clean beauty
does the same thing if something has a potentially
dangerous substance in it then it gets a prop
65 warning it doesn't matter what dose you
get and how you get it whether you inhale
it or eat it or put it on your skin these
different exposures are pretty darn fundamental
when it comes to toxicology obviously injecting
a liter of something versus putting half a
drop on your skin are going to have very different
effects
but that aside more importantly no safe harbor
in proposition 65 doesn't mean that something
is so bad that no level is allowed it actually
means that they just haven't decided on a
safe level yet there are lots of chemicals
that don't have a level and they're slowly
being added to proposition 65 and this makes
more sense because if benzophenone was so
bad it's never allowed then grapes would be
illegal in california grapes naturally have
benzophenone in them
the paper also says that 70% of benzophenone
that you put on your skin gets absorbed but
if you look at the study that they refer to
it's 70% absorption under occlusion in other
words 70% absorbs if you apply it and then
wrap it up in cling wrap which is not how
we wear sunscreen the paper does an uncovered
absorption as well and this is a much less
scary sounding 44% it's in the same table
it's right next to 70% so for some reason
the authors quoted the less relevant measurement
also it was done in monkeys
so to me there seems to be a sort of pattern
in how the authors are selecting and presenting
the evidence about benzophenone
now the authors don't just disagree with the
scientific consensus about benzophenone toxicology
they also disagree with dermatologists about
sunscreen the authors implied that dermatologists
and marketing propaganda shouldn't be taken
seriously when they recommend wearing sunscreen
regularly throughout the year and reapplying
sunscreen i don't think i have to point this
out but this is the medical consensus from
all of these organizations
and then joining the ranks of people that
the authors disagree with because haters gonna
hate hate hate hate hate there's me apparently
i'm part of various propaganda sources and
while i'm really flattered to be cited not
just once but twice it's also really bizarre
although maybe not that bizarre in the context
of this paper i'm a youtuber i'm not a huge
media outlet and i'm not an academic i mean
this is me and the two blog posts that got
cited were actually some of the least propagandary
of my posts they were the ones where i talked
about the studies that the fda did that the
media reported as sunscreen chemicals soak
all the way into your bloodstream sunscreens
seep into your blood i pointed out that we
don't have to freak out about sunscreens and
change sunscreens
my sneaky propaganda tactics were quoting
actual lines from the study quoting the fda
who did the study quoting the editors of the
journal that published the study quoting experts
quoting the american academy of dermatology
i guess maybe the authors think that we're
all propaganda and we should be listening
to the media headlines instead maybe this
is impostor syndrome talking but i don't really
feel like i'm doing that well at this whole
propaganda thing
so why did a bunch of scientists come out
with a paper that makes so many unusual claims
i mean i've read a lot of peer-reviewed papers
but disputing the scientific consensus of
cancer organizations and toxicologists and
dermatologists without much evidence and citing
a beauty blogger it's really just a lot in
the one paper well i think looking at what
else the authors have done gives a bit of
insight here like i said four of them are
from an ocean research institute and one of
them used to be a human toxicologist i think
the obvious question is why didn't they collaborate
with an academic who currently works in human
toxicology the only author who specializes
in human toxicology on this paper that talks
a lot about human toxicology is someone who
firstly isn't affiliated with an academic
institution but also he's retired and he doesn't
have a phd it's weird i know this sounds elitist
but that's just how scientific academia works
your first step in your training is getting
a phd
and it's not a one-off either it's a bit of
a pattern in the publication history of the
first two authors craig downs and joseph dinardo
craig downs is the scientist who published
and promoted the coral studies that led to
the whole reef-safe sunscreen thing in 2018
he's been very active in getting particular
chemical sunscreens banned in places like
hawaii since then he's published more studies
on how sunscreen impacts aquatic organisms
which is what you'd expect from a marine biologist
but he's also started collaborating with joseph
dinardo author 2 on papers about human toxicology
the only link between these papers and his
older work is that they're all about how bad
chemical sunscreen is in all sorts of different
ways which is weird scientists usually have
expertise in a specific field and they specialize
in particular methodologies they don't jump
around different fields focusing on a specific
group of chemicals
this publication history doesn't make a lot
of sense in my opinion but if you look at
some of the other things that downs and dinardo
have said outside of their peer reviewed publications
then you can sort of see that all roads seem
to lead back to chemical sunscreens
increasing melanoma rates? it's because of
too much sunscreen even though dermatologists
and the american academy of dermatology and
the skin cancer foundation all say that sunscreen
can reduce skin cancer they say that the increasing
melanoma rates are because of better detection
and different lifestyle habits apparently
they're wrong
declining coral reefs "it's my professional
opinion that most of the coral reefs in the
last 40 years have died because of your bathroom
than anything else climate change oil spills
what have you" i think this goes without saying
but this is very much not what most coral
scientists think the consensus is that the
biggest threats to coral are climate change
ecosystem changes from things like overfishing
and land-based pollution from things like
agriculture there's a recent open access review
that looks at all the studies on sunscreen
and coral the measurements that downs took
around hawaii were ten to a thousand times
higher than any other published measurements
the conclusion is "organic uv filters do occur
in the environment but according to our analysis
there is limited evidence to suggest that
their presence is causing significant harm
to coral reefs" although more research should
be done as you might have expected dinardo
has said that their lead author was hired
by big sunscreen
now i think there are definitely lots of legitimate
criticisms of the beauty and personal care
industry and we can't just trust everything
they say i mean i talk about marketing myths
all the time but that doesn't mean that the
complete opposite of what the industry says
is always going to be true and what are the
chances that everyone in the industry and
in toxicology dermatology and coral science
are all in on the same conspiracy to protect
big sunscreen people like to blab in a decades-old
conspiracy there's going to be thousands of
people involved how has no one leaked receipts
about all their secret meetings and how people
are getting paid off
i think if you have to dispute the scientific
consensus in multiple fields to support your
theory including fields that you don't have
expertise in and you don't have strong evidence
that other people haven't seen before to support
your theory then maybe it's time to ask yourself
if maybe you're being a bit biased
what about the other three authors i mentioned
this before but one of the weird things about
this paper is where it took off it's a paper
in english and the authors are from the us
and france in france the paper took off almost
immediately after it was published it was
all over the media but in the US there was
barely a blip this discrepancy is really weird
skincare people talk about sunscreen all the
time but for everyone else and the media in
general interest in sunscreen is cyclical
there are exceptions but it's pretty rare
for people to care this much about a small
study in a country where people mostly just
wear sunscreen to the beach if at all so what's
going on
here's one suggestion i've seen from french
bloggers and beauty experts if you look at
the conflicts of interest section of the paper
that ocean research institute that four of
the authors work at has partnerships with
pierre fabre a huge french cosmetic and pharmaceutical
company a few days after this paper was published
pierre fabre announced that they were launching
a sunscreen with a new filter called triasorb
and octocrylene-free features heavily in their
marketing the timing and the hype that was
almost entirely isolated to one country does
seem a bit suspicious but pierre fabre have
denied any involvement
i don't think that a conflict of interest
means that the science will automatically
be compromised it's unfortunate that science
is expensive and a lot of topics just aren't
that high up on the priority list for the
government to fund them without commercial
interest but it's a bit of a strange juxtaposition
with all this stuff in the paper about marketing
propaganda and big sunscreen
another study came out from a belgian research
group at the end of march and they found that
benzophenone increased after octocrylene sunscreens
were kept at high temperatures so again i
don't think the experiment part of this study
was wrong but if you compare the two papers
you can see how differently the two papers
contextualize their findings the other paper
mentions that benzophenone is a potential
endocrine disruptor and carcinogen but it
really highlights the potential part
there are a bunch of other things i haven't
mentioned that to me also seem like pretty
big red flags for example dinardo's public
email address for a while was chemicalsrtoxic@gmail.com
downs' lab runs a program that's a lot like
the ewg approved label where they'll certify
that your sunscreens are reef safe for a fee
last minute edit: last week one of the authors
from the lab affiliated with pierre fabre
commented on my coral reef post about adding
info on octocrylene being bad I'm not sure
why he's reaching out to someone he called
a "propaganda source" seems kinda sus
so what are the takeaways from this with octocrylene
and benzophenone the vast majority of scientists
don't think that benzophenone is as bad as
the paper makes it out to be but the amount
can get higher than expected although it is
still within the margin of safety for oral
exposure so hopefully there'll be a bit more
research on how benzophenone affects humans
when we put it on our skin and sunscreen formulators
will focus on ways of stabilizing octocrylene
in the meantime as many skincare experts have
said it's probably still safe to use octocrylene
sunscreens as long as you're not allergic
to them but it's safest to not use sunscreens
after their used by date and not expose them
to high temperatures which you were hopefully
doing anyway
the wider takeaway is that you can't trust
everything you read just because it's in a
peer-reviewed paper this paper had five authors
who all apparently signed off on this and
there were four anonymous reviewers as well
stuff slips through peer review all the time
especially when it's commentary around the
relevance of the research that part isn't
checked anywhere near as thoroughly as the
actual experimental part of the paper
now for some propaganda from big learning
if you like poisoning your brain with education
you're going to love this the first thousand
to click the link in the description will
get a free trial of skillshare's premium membership
skillshare is an online community with a massive
range of classes on all sorts of propaganda-y
topics like photography design video editing
time management classes are mostly less than
an hour so you can quickly level up and get
those propaganda bucks i usually use skillshare
to help me make better content for big sunscreen
but recently i've been watching a lot of classes
about cooking there's a lot of big delicious
propaganda on there from real life chefs i
recently took a class to sharpen ha my knife
skills with elana karp from plated and apparently
i was holding my knife wrong the whole time
and now i'm the latest victim of big not chopping
your fingers off it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription check out the
link in the description